je vais donc lire le discours qu'en ce
moment même le premier ministre lee
devant l'assemblée avec une difficulté
que je me permettrai de vous aussi allez
au passage l'union européenne vient de
vivre des moments difficiles et même
historique
il y a toujours des esprits résignés ils
pensent que l'on ne peut plus écrire
l'histoire que nos vieilles nations
fatigué par le fardeau des siècles
devrait renoncer que nos destins se
décident ailleurs indépendamment de nos
volontés et il ya bien sûr que ton
exister ce qu'ils souhaitent voir
l'europe se disloquer nos compatriotes
qui ont suivi les évolutions sur ce plan
au jour le jour ont bien senti qu'il y
avait quelque chose de fondamental qui
était en cause et que notre destin
pouvait basculer car bien sûr c'est
l'avenir de la grèce mais une certaine
façon c'est l'avenir d'un construction
européenne qui était en cause
et une fois encore au moment où nous
exprimons il faut constater que l'europe
est en train de surmonter une crise qui
aurait pu être fatale sans un accord en
effet nous aurions laissé un pays
abandonner un peuple à un sort
extrêmement difficile d'évaluation
inflation effondrement des salaires
faillite des banques des entreprises
risque de division de déstabilisation
avec et c'est moi qu'il ajoute il faut
le souligner des conséquences pas
seulement économique mais géopolitique
et géostratégique on en a parlé l'autre
jour que personne ne peut venir sans un
accord nous aurions donné une image
inquiétante de l'europe vis-à-vis du
monde c'est à dire de tous nos
partenaires des états unis de la chine
et des autres grands pays et nous
aurions d'une certaine façon tirer un
trait sur une certaine conception de la
solidarité européenne la france ne
pouvait pas l'accepter
et au nom du gouvernement je l'avais dit
ici même il ya peu de jours mais notre
pays un super entendre sa voix peser de
tout son poids avec en particulier le
président de la république nous avons
estimé qu'on ne fait pas sortir un pays
de l'union comme cela au gré des aléas
et que le fatalisme les égoïsmes chacun
pour soi quelles que soient les
difficultés ne pouvaient pas être le
langage de l'europe
la semaine dernière je me rappelle que
beaucoup d'entre vous et eux mêmes tous
sans doute aviez souhaité que nous
débattions ici pour que la parole de la
représentation nationale se fassent
entendre et le président larcher était
intervenu en ce sens est en effet
l'europe doit se construire avec le
peuple et ses représentants est longue
c'est dans cette même logique que le
prêt dans la république premier ministre
ont souhaité que le parlement se
prononce par un vote sur le contenu de
l'accord alors quelques mots sur cet
accord d'abord il est la réaffirmation
que la place de la grèce est dans la
zone rouge est pleinement dans l'union
européenne
il n'y a donc pas de mots et pas très
joli de greg site ni de ce qu'on appelle
le grec sites temporaires
il devrait en fait dangereuse et
finalement quand on réfléchit aux
mécanismes assez impraticable qui
reviendrait sans doute au même
nous entendons parler d'humiliation mais
même si les choses sont très difficiles
l'humiliation aurait été sans doute pour
ce pays d'être chassé de la monnaie
unique alors que l'immense majorité des
grecs souhaitent la conserver et cet
accord c'est aussi la réaffirmation de
la volonté de 19 états souverains de
préserver l'intégrité et la stabilité de
la zone euro
quand on regarde les choses en détails
et c'est l'objet bien sûr de votre vote
l'accord ce sont trois séries de
dispositions principales la première
c'est que la grèce va pouvoir disposer
de financements importants en
contrepartie d'engagements sur un
certain nombre de réformes
il y à un nouveau programme d'aidé
financière sur trois ans dans le cadre
de ce qu'on appelle le mécanisme
européen de stabilité
entre 82 et 86 milliards d'euros qui
s'ajoutent à deux précédents programmes
c'est malheureusement indispensable au
regard de la situation financière et
économique d'un pays qui ne peut
aujourd'hui absolument pas se financer
sur les marchés
la négociation de ce programme va
prendre nécessairement plusieurs
semaines il ya donc urgence à mettre en
place un financement relais dans les
tout prochains jours
la grèce a devant elle d'importantes
échéances de remboursement notamment
vis-à-vis de la bce qui a joué et joue
un rôle majeur pour apporter des
liquidités et c'est pourquoi la france
est pleinement mobilisé pour définir
avec ses partenaires
les modalités de ce financement le
nouveau programme d'aidé financière sur
trois ans exigez c'est normal le respect
de conditions strictes
les pelles l'union lient leur destin et
donc il se donne des règles qui doit
valoir pour tous dès ce soir
la grèce devrait voter des réformes
importantes pour qu'il y ait plus de
recettes
concernant la tva et sur le système de
retraites toujours sujet très délicat
pour en garantir la viabilité
la semaine prochaine la grèce doit faire
adopter le code de procédure civile car
il faut accélérer des procédures
judiciaires et réduire les coûts et elle
devra mener ensuite d'importantes
réformes pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de son économie je cite
notamment le marché des biens de
consommation l'énergie ou encore le
marché du travail
un programme de privatisation est
également prévue il y aura fonds
indépendant localisé en grèce est placée
sous l'autorité du gouvernement grec et
la france y assister pour que la
souveraineté de la grèce sont respectées
ce fonds va donc gérer la vente d'un
certain nombre d'actifs les produits
générés permettront la grèce de disposer
progressivement d'une somme d'un montant
total de 50 milliards d'euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent pour encore rembourser
la recapitalisation des banques
diminuer la dette et soutenir
l'investissement et donc la croissance
enfin la grèce s'engage à moderniser en
profondeur sur l'administration publique
elle va créer notamment
un échange des statistiques indépendante
rappelez vous qu'il y avait eu des
controverses sur des travestissement de
la réalité
les choix faits par le gouvernement de
monsieur tsipras ce ne sont certainement
pas des choix facile alors qu'ils ont
déjà suivi les effets d'une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent
les grecs devront faire des efforts
supplémentaires supplémentaires mais là
est tout le problème
indispensable est sans commune mesure
j'ai insiste avec l'appauvrissement de
la population grecque qu'aurait provoqué
agric site il faut toujours préparer de
solution même si les deux ont leurs
inconvénients
il faut saluer le courage du premier y
qui prend ici des décisions difficiles
mais nécessaires dans l'intérêt
supérieur de son pays
et quand on veut soutenir la grèce et
monsieur cipra ce alors il est
préférable de ne pas faire le jeu de
ceux qui voudraient sa sortie de la zone
euro essentiellement par idéologie un
certain nombre milite aujourd'hui pour
refuser l'accord mais si on les suivait
cela pourrait faire en réalité le
malheur des grecs malgré le chemin
choisi est davantage celui de la vérité
de la responsabilité le gouvernement
grec doit aussi rétablir la confiance
avec les partenaires européens
car beaucoup de temps assurément a été
perdue depuis le mois de février
mais il faut penser que c'est le seul
chemin qui peut sortir durablement le
pays de la crise et lui rendent donc sa
souveraineté et des grecs ils tiennent
beaucoup avec raison sa fierté qu à
réformer son pays modernisés sur
l'économie à bâtir un état moderne qui
fonctionne mettre en place une vraie
fiscalité sont des nécessités pour un
pays qui veut renouer avec les
nécessaire compétitivité et la grèce le
sait et il faut pas oublier mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que la plupart
des réformes figurant dans le texte de
l'accord sont reprises des propositions
du gouvernement du premier ministre et
prince qui ont été approuvées par le
parlement grec
dans la nuit du
11 une deuxième mesure important de cet
accord c'est le traitement de la dette
c'était vital pour la grèce pour qu'elle
puisse commencer à envisager un avenir
qui ne se limite pas au seul
remboursement l'eurogroupe en ce moment
réfléchit à des mesures permettant la
grèce de retrouver un peu d'oxygène et
de garantir la soutenabilité de la dette
qui s'élève aujourd'hui à 180% de sa
richesse ce point était capitale pour le
premier type race il a obtenu formalité
international encore redit ce matin il
fallait alléger la dette grecque
et c'est bien ce que nous allons faire
en profilant la dette ce qui pourrait
passer mais ce n'est pas encore décidée
par l allongement de la durée de
remboursement ou encore une réduction
des taux d'intérêt et puis dès la
troisième mesure qui est importante elle
aussi même si on a peut souligner c'est
que les grecs vont disposer d'un
programme d'investissement de 35
milliards au service de ce qui doit être
la relance de la croissance
cette somme viendra à la fois d'une
utilisation des fonds structurels et des
différents programmes de l'union
européenne mais aussi de ce qu'on
appelle le plan juncker
ce que nous portons à l'échelle
européenne s'agissant la stratégie
économique amenez vos si dans ce cas
pour ce pays
il peut pas y avoir de réforme efficace
s'il n'y a pas des investissements et de
la croissance
nous avons ici à l'accord donc difficile
mais nous a paraît-il responsable et qui
doit s'inscrire dans la durée et je veux
saluer l'implication du ministre des
finances michel sapin qui a oeuvré sans
relâche pour approcher des points mais
bien sûr nous n'ignorons pas les
difficultés et il y aura encore
assurément des rendez vous compliqué
pour l'agresser pour l'europe la grèce
va recevoir je viens d'en parler plus de
milliards d'euros dettes financières et
35 milliards d'euros au service de la
croissance et voir sa dette rééchelonnée
il y à des réformes menées mais sans
cela c'est à dire ces deux aspects les
difficultés lourdes réapparaîtront et si
les réformes sont très exigeantes c'est
aussi il faut le dire parce qu'elle
n'avait jamais été menés cet accord ce
n'est pas un chèque en blanc
parce que nous demandons beaucoup à la
grèce n'ont pas évidemment comme on le
lit ici ou là pour l'accueillir cela
n'aurait pas de chance mais pour
l'accompagner dans un redressement
économique qui est absolument
indispensable
ayant à l'esprit ceci c'est que
l'absence d'accord et là encore il faut
comparer deux pistes auraient abouti
avec certitude à ce que les 40 milliards
de prêts que les contribuables français
ont fait aux grecs disparaissent à
jamais ceux qui ont tout fait pour ce
qu'on appelle gré de sites et qui ont
appelé à punir comme on le dit les grecs
appelé en fait à nous punir nous mêmes
grâce à l'action de la france et
d'autres pays se sont finalement aussi
les intérêts des contribuables français
qui sont protégés alors le rôle de la
france la france a agi je crois que
personne ne le conteste et
singulièrement le président la
république pour cet accord
c'était notre rôle et c'était son rôle
c'était ce qu'on attendait notre pays et
il s'agissait de privilégier l'intérêt
général et en l'occurrence celui de
l'europe
avant aussi une responsabilité envers la
grèce et le peuple grec
j'ai rappelé la semaine dernière que des
liens singuliers vous l'avez tous
souligné qu'ils sont de nature
historique intellectuels et autres nous
unissent à ce pays
peut-être parce que même pas rentrer
dans une
philosophie facile nous sommes des
nations qui partageant une même ambition
un peu plus large que nous-mêmes et même
parfois universel et il y a longtemps la
grèce plus récemment la france
nous avons voulu que notre voix porte au
delà de nos frontières et qu'elle est en
quelque sorte un écho beaucoup plus
large et nous estimons sans utiliser de
trop grands mots que s'agissant de la
france
il n'est pas possible d'abandonner la
grèce qu' abandonner la grèce ce serait
d'une certaine manière renoncer à ce que
nous portons
si notre voie a pesé c'est pour
différentes raisons et notamment parce
que sur cet aspect nous avons fait
preuve de beaucoup de constance
nous ne sommes pas laisser voguer au gré
des calculs d'appareils des
atermoiements ou de certaines certains
contre pied tactique du moment nous
avons préféré avoir une ligne et nous y
tenir
si la france est au rendez vous c'est
parce que cette cohérence a été je crois
assuré et voilà ce que nous avons essayé
de porter jusqu'aux la question de la
france et de l'allemagne a été souvent
posée et j'ajoute ça sent la négociation
iranienne qui comportait de longs jours
et de non moins longue nuit
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec mon collègue
et ami monsieur steinmeier il y a eu un
certain moment tel ou tel aspect
différent mais finalement l'europe et la
france ont pu compter sur la solidité du
couple franco-allemand en allant puiser
à la source de ce qui fait cette
relation particulière
nous savons bien que l'allemagne et la
france ont non seulement dépassé les
haines mais que la réconciliation est au
delà des ressentiments des souffrances
et de tel aspect du moment et cette
dimension là on l'a vu prévaloir la
france et l'allemagne représentée en
l'espèce par le président de la
république et la chancelière
on agit semble-t-il nous semble-t-il
avec la conscience d'être les héritiers
de tout cela et de la nécessité
historique et pense que il faut
condamner avec beaucoup de force
l'excès et même parfois la dignité de
certains propos avec des relents
nationalistes et des phrases qui en
cherchant inutilement atteindre
l'allemagne font aussi du mal à l'europe
et à la france
formez un couple ça ne veut pas dire
être d'accord sur tout mais c'est savoir
le moment venu se retrouver sur
l'essentiel il peut y avoir des
divergences des désaccords des
sensibilités différentes qui sont aussi
celles de l'eau peuple l'allemagne est
savoie à la france a la sienne c'est
celle d'une europe solidaire et
responsable qui n'exclut personne et qui
s'est rassemblée mais la solidité d'une
amitié ces pros aussi au moment des
difficultés et je pense au final la
france et l'allemagne ont fait preuve au
moment des décisions d'une grande unité
parce que nous savions au fond que si
nous voulions trouver une solution il
fallait agir de concert comme franco
allemand doit être décidée en messieurs
équilibré il peut pas tout parce que il
des riches à l'europe mais sans lui il
faut convenir que l'europe ne peut pas
grand-chose dames et messieurs les
sénateurs la france conçoit son destin
au coeur de l'europe c'est notre fierté
c'est notre vocation et nous avons
l'intention de défendre et nous voulons
une certaine europe alors les mots sont
peut-être plus trop généraux or
volontaires généreuse c'est nécessaire à
cause de l'époque
notre monde est fait de bouleversements
de menaces d'instabilité et nous
essayons d'être à l'initiative
nous jouons tous notre rôle ici pour
l'europe partout où il le faut et où
nous le pouvons
sahel en irak route le terrorisme au
moyen-orient avec la question du
nucléaire iranien
et c'est là où j'ai prouvé une
difficulté puisque en obligations
gouvernementales nécessite que je lise
la phrase
est proposé je veux saluer l'action
déterminée le talent de négociateur de
laurent fabius
je vais donc vous présenter mes excuses
j'ai fait la remarque au premier
ministre j'étais tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée à ses côtés il m'a dit mais
c'est pas la première fois
tu avais lu un discours de moi où je
disais fils d'espagnol c'est donc tu
avais une défaite des difficultés
j'avais trouvé une formule là il ya la
même formule mais ce n'est qu'un exemple
de plus de ma modestie connus ou encore
bon le pass
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'europe dans la situation nous sommes
dans le monde troublé qui le dos tu dois
choisir et il faut absolument si nous
voulons pouvoir avoir la force de nos
choix être unie et si par malheur nous
étions des unis à ce moment là ce serait
un coup très très forts portés à
l'europe et donc par contre coup à la
france un travail important
revenons à notre projet d'accord reste à
faire pour mettre concrètement en oeuvre
cet accord parlement grec doit se
prononcer ce soir
d'autres vont le faire dans les
prochains jours mais il faudra aller au
delà
nous devons avoir la force politique de
tirer toutes les leçons de cette crise
pour en faire si c'est possible
une opportunité déjà nous avions tracé
quelques lignes quelques pistes dans
notre discussion de la semaine dernière
et le président de la république hier
dans son intervention a formulé quelques
lignes de propositions en ce sens il
nous semble que nous avons d'abord
besoin d'un véritable gouvernement
économique de la zone euro au service
d'abord de la croissance et l'emploi
il y a eu des progrès avec l'union
bancaire avec ce qu'on appelle
terrible charbon le sommet est européen
mais ce n'est pas assez il faut une
coordination accrue des politiques
économiques qui donne sa pleine place à
une analyse globale de la zone euro avec
ses forces ses vulnérabilités ses
besoins donc ça c'est une première
aspects et le gouvernement français aura
l'occasion dans les semaines qui
viennent de préciser ses propositions il
faut aussi plus de convergence ça fait
longtemps que nous disons qu'il faut
regarder les choses en face une même
monnaie n'a pas permis à nos économies
de converger spontanément suffisamment
et même parfois c'est le contraire qui
s'est produit
ce n'est pas bon et ce n'est pas ça nous
devons avancer en faisant par le haut
dans les différents domaines sur le
domaine économique sur le domaine social
en rapprochant aussi les éléments
fiscaux en utilisant tous les
instruments à notre disposition
la politique de cohésion pour accéder à
la page économique et sociale entre
états le plan uk les rapprochements dans
le domaine social avec les pays qui sont
prêts qu'ils sont prêts pendant je pense
en particulier à la question des
rémunérations et l'harmonisation et la
lutte contre les stratégies
d'optimisation fiscale
ce sont les sujets qui ne sont pas
faciles ni techniquement et
politiquement mais les différences qui
existent nuisent à l'unité et à la
stabilité de la zone euro
et puis nous avons également besoin de
nous doter de moyens budgétaires
il y a le plan juncker qui a été mis en
place ce qui est court leur ex-allié de
projets européens en moins de six mois
nous devrons nous semble-t-il aller plus
loin en mettant en place dans un
deuxième temps un véritable budget de la
zone euro permettant de financer des
investissements spécifiques en matière
d'infrastructures d'innovation ou encore
de capital humain avec les ressources
correspondantes ce sont quelques pistes
et nous les préciseront dans les
semaines qui viennent on ne réalisera
pas assez avancé et on ne pourra pas
engager de nouvelles étapes en matière
d'intégration sans les peuples et leurs
représentants c'est pourquoi il faut là
aussi renforcer la légitimité
démocratique de la zone euro cela
concerne l'europe bien
/ car aujourd'hui tout le monde le
constate le parlement européen n'est pas
suffisamment associés aux travaux du
sommet est européen
concrètement la recommandation zone euro
élaboré chaque année pour être transmise
au parlement européen et faire l'objet
d'un débat démocratique
en outre et c'est plus complexe mais
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus novateurs
nous devons pouvoir l'invité à
s'organiser pour que les sujets propres
à la zone euro soient davantage pris en
considération en tant que tel ce n'est
pas le cas et c'est le sens de l'appel
du président de la république à mettre
en place une sorte de parlement de la
zone euro et il faudra aussi bien sûr
associé à cette action les parlements
nationaux
si nous prenons encore davantage de
hauteur ou de recul
cette crise montre combien nous devons
reprendre le chantier du projet européen
dans sa globalité avec vision avec
ambition avec audace car si la défiance
s'installe où je crois si les
populations gronde c'est aussi parce que
l'europe depuis beaucoup de temps a
perdu de son élan et parce que souvent
l'europe ne dit pas clairement vers où
elle va ou en tout cas qu'on ne comprend
pas de ce qu'elle dit lorsqu'elle
s'exprime dans besoin de plus
d'intégration de plus de solidarité pour
la protection la prospérité des peuples
c'est vrai sur les questions économiques
et monétaires qui sont absolument
essentielles c'est vrai aussi sur
d'autres enjeux
et vous pensez comme moi aux questions
migratoires où seule une politique
vraiment commune et efficace pourra nous
permettre d'avancer
et puis l'europe c'est plus que notre
continent et c'est plus sans doute que
la somme des intérêts spécifiques de nos
nations
c'est un certain nombre de messages a
certain nombre de valeurs qui peuvent
résonner dans le monde entier les
européens
je constate ne le savent pas toujours
une savent pas toujours non plus
défendre au mieux leurs propres intérêts
nous devons donc nous appuyer sur nos
forces sur nos talents pour peser
davantage sur l'ordre du monde
que ce soit dans le domaine commercial
où l'union européenne fait figure de
géant dans le domaine de la culture où
nous industries sont puissantes dans le
domaine environnemental où nous faisons
la course en tête
déjà depuis plusieurs décennies je les
ai vus encore dans la négociation
iranienne où il y avait nos trois pays
européens la france la grande bretagne
l'allemagne et puis la haute
représentante qui coordonnait un certain
nombre de travaux
l'europe ne doit pas avoir peur d'être
pleinement elle-même et elle doit
assumer qui elle est ce qu'elle fait et
le porter mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
vous avez être les premiers en europe à
voter la responsabilité est donc
d'indiquer le chemin et vous serez
associé aux prochaines étapes de mise en
oeuvre de l'accord
face à une crise ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le dépit ne veut pas être une
option
il faut aller vers le rebond comme dans
tout bon discours il y à la fin une
citation cette fois ci du poète allemand
holger line qui rend hommage en
l'occurrence à l'île grecque de patmos
et qui a écrit là où est le père il l'a
aussi croit ce qui sauve c'est ce que je
vous disais la semaine dernière me
rappelant mes humanités grecques c'est
le même mot qui en grec ancien
signe d'une hausse signifie le risque ou
la chance la crise que nous venons de
connaître est aussi ce qui peut et doit
nous permettre si nous voulons de faire
aujourd'hui preuve d'ambition pour
l'europe
alors essayons par nos votes d'avancé et
si on veut continuer à écrire l'histoire
de l'europe c'est à dire l'histoire de
l'eau peuple et c'est aujourd'hui
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs par
votre vote
votre responsabilité merci
monsieur le ministre